the Lego Batman movie was a ton of fun
and had loads of cool moments in it lots
of which I've talked about in my Easter
eggs video but what I want to talk about
here is the stuff that didn't make it
into the final film
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to break
down some of the fascinating deleted
scenes and rejected concepts from the
movie I'm also giving away a second set
of awesome Lego Batman movie books that
is the essential guide plus the making
of the movie which features concept art
sketches and Lego builds for a chance to
win make sure you subscribe and leave a
comment on this video about your
favorite deleted scene or what you'd
like to see in a sequel and for bonus
ways to enter the giveaway check out the
gleam link in the video description
below
quick alert there are spoilers ahead so
to avoid those grab the nearest bat
train out of here by clicking or tapping
the screen for my spoiler free review of
the film Lego Batman director Chris
McKay says that the idea for the Phantom
Zone housing various villains and the
wider Lego universe was inspired by
movies like cabin in the woods and Last
Action Hero
McKay wanted to bring in a bunch of
crazy villains that didn't exist in the
Batman or DC Comics universe and mix
them up with a bunch of Batman
characters and we do get a number of
uber villains such as Voldemort our Ron
and the Daleks in the movie but there
were also some r-rated villains that
McKay wanted to include in the film but
he had to leave them out as they weren't
appropriate for a younger audience
dropped from the final film was bill
from Quentin Tarantino's Kill Bill
Stephen King's Annie from the 1990
horror movie misery and bill the butcher
from Gangs of New York apparently housed
in 2001 a Space Odyssey was also removed
as a character didn't read well in the
movie although Barbara Gordon has a
backstory in the movie which differs
quite considerably from her various
comic book incarnations early versions
of the character were initially also
quite different to what's in the final
film originally barbara was known to be
a librarian at the Gotham City Library
and was secretly involved in outside the
law vigilante activities in one early
design her vigilante persona carries a
copy of The Scarlet Pimpernel who is a
character created in the last century
who also held a secret hero identity or
was a literary forerunner of characters
like Batman before deciding on a more
classic design for Robin some zany
options were considered including
Robin Hood inspired costume a
contemporary hoodie and a gymnast outfit
there was also a storyboard scene that
was cut which featured an open day at
dick Grayson's orphanage where he tried
to get attention from prospective
parents who might adopt him and as a
reference to this in the final movie
when Dick Grayson asked Bruce Wayne for
advice on how to improve his adoption
chances we get to see the Joker cruising
around in his notorious lowrider during
the movie but the lego design team
considered numerous other rides for the
Clown Prince of Crime and his sidekick
villains including an octopus and slide
vehicle that looked really cool there
were also some other Joker truck designs
that incorporated some of his classic
weapons such as a handshake joy buzzer
which electrocutes its victims and the
squirting flower that the Joker has
often worn on his jacket and which
spewed toxic gas or acid at its victims
The Joker's partner-in-crime Harley
Quinn has a rich history in the DC
Universe and numerous possible costume
designs were considered before the
filmmakers decided on her character's
final looks in the movie we also briefly
see her alter ego psychiatrist dr.
Harleen Quinzel alternative versions of
Quinzel were also considered but didn't
make it to the final film for example a
holistic therapist who provided massages
acupuncture and other treatments to
clients such as Batman
the two-face we see in the movie is the
LEGO version of what director Chris
McKay thought Billy Dee Williams as
two-face would have looked like if he
had a chance to appear on screen I shall
no doubt remember Billy Dee Williams
played Harvey Dent in Tim Burton's 1989
Batman movie but the character was
dropped from the sequel Batman Returns
alternate designs the two-face were
considered for the Lego Batman movie
though each of which paid homage to the
various incarnations the character has
appeared in the comics and on the big
and small screen over the years the
joseph's henchmen each have their own
rides and many of them also had some
very cool designs that were rejected for
the final movie The Riddler had designed
for a question mark shaped helicopter
and a double-decker berth but those were
dropped and instead he got his own
sports car there also various feline
inside vehicles considered a Catwoman
before the filmmakers settled on a
motorcycle and various wacky flying
contraptions were designed for scarecrow
before he ended up with a much simpler
flying broomstick inspired helicopter
there are also a few scenes from the
trailers it didn't
it into the final movie such as a
deleted gag where Bruce Wayne is
beatboxing and then tells Alfred's that
he should always be recording and then
we've seen a Batman running with the
other Justice League members in the
background
hence the deleted action scene with
Batman and the rest of the Justice
League
shipping Batgirl and Batman has been a
controversial subject among comic book
fans that resurfaced in last year's
animated Killing Joke movie which
included a now infamous sex scene
between the two characters marketing for
the Lego Batman movie seemed to play up
the possibility of a romantic
relationship between Batgirl and Batman
and there was a scene in a TV spot where
Barbara Gordon comments that it's been a
great first day and Batman thinks she
said first date in the final movie this
joke was cut out perhaps to the relief
of many fans of course the film still
played around with Batman having a crush
on Barbara however it doesn't lead
anywhere
and Batman jokes at the end that she's
his platonic coworker buddy who's a girl
but just a friend one of the best scenes
from the movie that we did see is where
Batman sings who's the Batman and
important to the story were other
musical themes like Michael Jackson's
man in the mirror and the final song
friends a family but director Chris
McKay is said that ideally he wanted to
make the whole movie a musical with
additional songs from different
characters perspectives integrated
throughout the film in the end the idea
of including additional musical numbers
was dropped as there wasn't enough time
to work these into the movie so guys
what do you think about the deleted
scenes villains and designs are there
any you would like to have seen in the
final movie and what would you like to
see happen in a Lego Batman sequel don't
forget to leave a comment and subscribe
for a chance to win this awesome pair of
Lego Batman movie books the bonus ways
to enter the giveaway check out the
gleam link in the video description
below if you enjoyed this do please hit
that like button and remember to turn on
your notifications for flicks in the
city so you can catch my new videos and
if you fancy finding out more about the
Lego Batman movie or other movie deleted
scenes you can tap or click here to do
just that thanks for watching and see
you next time you be going we be lovers